[Musique]
cette image a été énormement vu l'homme
doit-il être sévèrement condamné l'homme
qui a fait sa merci
icy merci d'être là merci à vous ici
[Musique]
exactement
en tant que travailleuse du sexe
c'était une manifestation pour contre la
réforme des retraites et vous avez le
temps
oui mais c'est important parce que
j'étais là pour dire que les [__] aussi
demandent l'accès le droit à la retraite
et on veut être juste considérer et
prise
dans la lutte ouvrière en fait vous avez
choisi depuis les seins nus
c'est un signe de protestation c'est
c'est
politiquement Corre et politique en tant
que femme trans et [__] mon corps est
politique et je m'en sers comme outil de
militantisme vous voulez faire passer un
message ou à comme ça tout à fait voilà
d'accord voilà une arme politique un
Powell est-ce que vous répondez à ceux
qui disent que vous avez voulu faire le
buzz
moi j'ai rien cherché du tout j'ai pas
cherché j'ai cherché aucun buzz de base
j'étais juste là en manifestation avec
mes amis j'ai pas cherché à être agressé
on m'a filmé sans me consentement et on
a publié la vidéo sans mon accord sur
Twitter
vous avez vu la vidéo vous êtes quoi
je m'attendais pas à ce que ça prenne
autant de proportion et alors
donc il y a cet homme qui va vous
approcher et vous accoucher qu'est-ce
qui vous a dit
je sais plus il voulait savoir en fait
si mes seins étaient siliconés ou pas
parce que il se demandait si j'étais
trans d'accord vous lui avez dit quoi
bah rien en fait quand il m'a touché je
lui ai dit c'était pas permis de toucher
en fait et après je vais cracher dessus
d'accord
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on se demande
tous comment vous avez vécu ce moment
vous l'avez vécu c'était vous êtes passé
à autre chose après et après vous avez
revu la vidéo vous êtes dire quand même
ou bien vous avez été marqué par cette
ce qui s'est passé tout de suite vous
êtes dit c'est grave je vais
marquer aussi par le harcèlement que je
subis encore aujourd'hui sur Twitter et
sur les autres réseaux sociaux de par la
diffusion de la vidéo en fait j'ai porté
plainte ou pas je vais pas porter
plainte j'ai rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine avec mon avocat vous attendez
quoi de la justice là pour là-dessus
quelle façon de travail et qu'elle me
reconnaisse
victime de cette agression sexuelle en
fait et que lui soit pénalisé alors on
vous a posé une question autour de la
table l'homme de tils c'est être
sévèrement condamné je vais surtout
prendre les noms parce que c'est ça qui
m'intrigue alors je voudrais Sophie
sévèrement ça va être compliqué étant
donné que ça peut être jusqu'à 50
prisons et 75000 euros d'amende pour ce
qui vient pour ce qu'il a fait on pourra
juste un attouchement oui alors oui qui
soit condamné oui effectivement c'est
vraiment mais il y a un truc que je
comprends pas très bien en fait c'est
vous dites que vous revendiquer enfin
vous utilisez votre corps comme un objet
politique effectivement politiquement
corne n'est pas un objet oui la personne
a effectivement pas le droit de se
permettre de vous toucher comme voilà
moi je j'aimerais pas qu'on fasse et je
comprends que ce soit un vrai problème
mais
non mais si enfin moi je veux
rien ne justifié qu'on vienne toucher
mon corps comme consentement je suis
d'accord avec vous mais en fait vous
vous retrouvez dans un truc où vous êtes
toute seule comme ça alors que les Femen
sont en groupe etc finalement vous étiez
tout seul dans cette manif et alors
mais vous étiez tout en train de
manifester pourquoi pour les réformes
des retraites ou pour la fiscalité pour
les prostituées etc j'ai pas compris le
propos en fait c'était quoi les
prostituées pour la retraite comme comme
les autres qu'elle soit considérée comme
des travailleurs en fait et comme tout
le monde j'ai des droits et j'ai droit à
la retraite mais vous étiez pas protégé
c'est à dire vous êtes toute seule vous
êtes comme ça
alors moi en fait je j'ai mis non parce
que je suis autant choqué par le geste
de de Monsieur que par le vôtre c'était
une manifestation familiale je respecte
alors je précise je respecte tout à fait
vos revendications en revanche parce que
vous payez des impôts donc vous devez
être considéré comme tout le monde donc
vous avez droit à une retraite ça il y a
pas de souci avec ça mais là je suis
autant choqué de vous voir défiler comme
ça dans une manifestation familiale vous
voulez provoquer vous avez voulu
évidemment provoqué c'est votre droit et
vous utilisez ça comme mais il faut pas
s'étonner après que on est en train il
faut pas s'étonner que bah non non
différent d'une personne qui marche
tranquillement dans la rue en mini-jupe
qui a tout à fait le droit et si on lui
met la main aux fesses alors là
vous vous êtes dans la provocation et
vous c'est votre droit je ne pratique
pas
même si je sors dans la rue complètement
à poil avec des plumes dans le cul rien
ne justifie qu'on vient de me toucher en
fait bah moi ça me choque autant les
deux voilà ce que je trouve dommage
madame c'est que et
aucun métier n'est pas jugé et c'est
très bien c'est juste que voilà qui vous
touche c'est dégueulasse mais ce que
vous venez de faire ce soir ce soir on a
regardé par des familles par des enfants
par ça se fait pas non et alors les
enfants ils ont jamais venus
à 20h on n'a pas envie que ses enfants
de 8 ans voient des seins pas forcément
donc il faut vous respecter ça dérange
pas il faut qu'il vous reste 4 mais
respecter les autres aussi madame la
terre vous l'avez pas fait voilà et
concernant les retraites ça notre sujet
mais vous savez très bien le problème
qu'il y a aussi avec les prostituées
c'est qu'elles sont payées en liquide et
que souvent dès que la pâte donc il y a
pas de retraite qui dérange en fait
c'est que je fais à 30 que je sois trans
et que je sois [__]
laisse-moi parler je suis venu là pour
parler ok c'est pas gilbertez
en fait les parents ça les dérange pas
que leur gosse voit des meufs à poil sur
les Pablo sur les panneaux publicitaires
pour vendre du carrelage
des femmes pardon non mais moi je suis
un gros porc
j'ai un gamin de 8 ans et que tu
découvres vos seins comme ça que j'ai
pas envie que tu partages sexuel en fait
la sexualisation elle est du côté de
celui qui regarde
ce que ce monsieur vous respecte et vous
respectez pas les téléspectateurs là
c'est quoi l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
ne sont pas forcément que des objets
sexuels c'est aussi des des objets
maternants qui permettent de donner les
données à manger aux enfants etc et donc
c'est aussi ça qu'elle dit et que c'est
déjà pas simplement quand tu vois des
Femen et que les Femen utilisent leur
corps justement comme une arme politique
et elle se met dans un projet c'est dans
un contexte là on parle des retraites du
coup on parle même plus du sujet on
parle que de vos seins
documentaire sur 20h50 ça serait du
moins de 13 ans voilà exactement
ouais le truc je crois enfin je trouve
au propos c'est dommage
honnêtement que votre combat est ta
gueule non mais là
en fait
d'habitude excuse-moi 2 minutes chérie
juste merci Mathieu et Haïti alors
allez-y moi je trouve que votre combat
est un homme mais je trouve que vous
êtes dans la provocation ça ne justifie
évidemment pas le geste que le monsieur
a eu mais si vous voulez me faire passer
un message par rapport aux gens qui sont
présents par rapport aux familles ça
fait que votre comportement peut choquer
ça pouvait l'entendre quand même ou vous
pouvez pas même pas l'entendre ça que
parfois ça puisse choquer des gens ben
c'est aussi un choquant qu'on a fait
avancer bien sûr on peut aussi rendre
compte que parfois certaines personnes
soient choquées ou déranger dans l'ordre
voilà dans leur contexte devant la
télévision elles sont pas hypocrites non
plus je ne sais pas si elles sont
hypocrite mais juste je vous respecte
de la République c'est quand même madame
avec le torse je comprends mais il faut
bien il faut être il faut être il faut
être il faut être à l'écoute
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a
Jean-Marie parce que en fait on peut
être nuit on n'est pas obligé de se
faire se toucher les seins moi j'ai
l'impression d'abord l'homme doit-il
être sévèrement sanctionné moi déjà moi
ce qui me trompe c'est effectivement
c'est qui vous touche votre poitrine
parce que il y a quelque part comme vous
êtes trans où il y a un côté un peu sous
race sous citoyen donc moi un peu animal
de foire moi qui me dérange et donc je
n'aime pas qu'on vous traite de cette
manière là et ça d'accord
que c'est un peu dégueulasse donc ça ça
me plaît pas après oui qui a un truc
aujourd'hui que vous soyez un peu là
présente sur ce plateau un peu militant
un peu dans la provocation parce que
c'est aussi une manière pour vous de
vous défendre parce que c'est très
compliqué quand on est harcelé de deux
de défendre et voilà et vous avez pas
l'habitude moi ça me choque pas je pense
qu'il sera pas sévèrement sanctionné
parce que voilà mais je pense que malgré
tout c'est pas bien qui vous est touché
il faut quand même dire que ça ça Daniel
qui était énervé
je commence enfin pourquoi parler de
transphobie moi j'ai su maintenant que
vous étiez trans j'ai cru que vous étiez
juste une [__] une femme donc je suis
désolé je suis peut-être débile
madame j'ai cru juste voilà vous étiez
une femme on touchait la poitrine bon ce
n'est pas bien je ne cautionne pas
évidemment mais arrêtez de mettre de la
transphobie là où il y en a pas je suis
sûr qu'il y a peu c'est ça transmis
parce que évidemment
il se posait la question de savoir si
j'étais trans et si médecin
[Applaudissements]
contre un poteau de ce que tu
fais attention au poteau
vous avez des couilles
alors que mademoiselle a un con a un
combat évidemment une lutte par rapport
à son identité qui est quand même
beaucoup plus courte beaucoup plus
[Rires]
pas de foyer bien le film je vous jure
et moi moi je comprends
parce que c'est un transit
vous allez porter plainte comme vous
l'avez dit et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
voilà il y a eu un petit débat avec
Daniel qui disait que elle elle pouvait
comprendre et Jean-Marie aussi mais moi
je dis que on fait pas ça pour effrayer
les moineaux donc quand on se balade la
poitrine à l'air évidemment s'expose
plus que si on a un survêtement
quelqu'un qui fait sur la plage qui fait
du topless s'il te plaît
c'est pas pareil là c'est pas possible
c'est un gros cochon à sexualiser les
seins des femmes
non mais non mais là
il doit y avoir condamnation parce qu'il
n'y a pas consentement il y a de sens de
consentement exactement on voit que
c'est tout simplement vous disiez chers
Sophie c'est un attouchement non c'est
purement et simplement une agression
sexuelle vous êtes des fous dans ce
contenu n'importe qui qui est torse nu
dans la rue on se dit bah non ça va
comme
ça
et se balader seins nus n'est pas
considéré comme de l'exhibition sexuelle
donc on ne peut rien lui reprocher sur
le plan légal non absolument pas donc
c'est une agression sexuelle purement et
simplement voilà voilà
moi j'hallucine de ce que j'entends
depuis tout ça tout à l'heure il y en a
certains qui disent qu'en fait si lui
arrivait ça c'est attouchement quelque
part que c'est un peu de sa faute mais
en fait rien ne justifie un attouchement
et moi je pense que ce mec effectivement
c'est un gros porc et je pense c'est
même pas une question de femme trans ou
pas femme trans je pense qu'il pourrait
faire ça avec des vrais femmes le mec il
est filmé il est en public ça lui pose
pas de problème de toucher un dessin ces
hommes là sont dangereux et il faut les
sanctionner sinon ça va continuer c'est
c'est horrible
merci en tout cas ici est-ce que vous
avez quelque chose à rajouter comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure mais je crois
que Mathieu voulait dire un dernier truc
parce que j'ai été lui faire un bisou
pendant la pluie parce que parce qu'en
fait on a le même combat qui est très
joli et je sens que vous êtes super bien
non mais je crois qu'elle peut pas te
blairer
je sens que vous êtes une personne qui
se ferait et je vous trouve très
courageux et oui il doit être sanctionné
et je vous souhaite le meilleur voilà et
moi franchement bah voilà on pense à
vous d'accord avec Mathieu en fait tu
communes le combat en fait c'est le
combat de nous tous en fait c'est pas
plus un combat pour un homosexuel qu'un
hétérosexuel ça doit être le combat de
nous tous en fait on a pas 100 personnes
non mais tu le sais Mathieu on n'a pas
touché la poitrine d'une femme quelle
qu'elle soit que tu sois homo ou hétéro
en fait voilà c'est pour ça mais bon